عناء سفر طويل وشوق للقاء طال انتظاره انه
حال خمس عائلات وصلت الى احد سجون دنيتك
للقاء ذويهم من الاسرى الاوكرانيين
من الوصول ايضا للقاء زوجها الاسير تامل
ان يجتمع الشمل قريبا
قضيت يومين في الطريق زوجي اسير منذ مارس
من العام الماضي لدينا طفله صغيره اصلي
يوميا كي يعود الى حضن اسرتنا
بعض صور العائليه وكثير من الذكريات
لحظات تختلط فيها المشاعر قبل اللقاء
لقاء لم يكن الاسرى على علم مسبق به
استمرت الزياره لدقائق معدوده
الى ان لحظاتها لا تقدر بثمن كما يقولها
اولاء منذ الاسابيع الاولى للحرب جرت
عمليات تبادل شملت اكثر من الفي اسير من
الجانبين تواصل العمل على هذا المسار يبقي
الامل في امكانيه توصل طرفي الصراع الى
تفاهمات بشان قضايا اخرى سياسيه وانسانيه
اكثر تعقيدا
يقدر عدد اسرى الجيش الاوكراني لدى روسيا
باكثر من 7000 اسير وتقدر اوكرانيا اسراها
بنحو 2500 فقط رغم عمليات التبادل التي
تجاوزت 30 عمليه منذ اندلاع الحرب تتهم
الامم المتحده الطرفين بانتهاكات بحق
الاسرع ويتبادل الطرفان ايضا الاتهامات
بشان وقوع انتهاكات وسط مطالبات دوليه
باحترام اتفاقيه جونيف بشان الاسرى
مستعدون لتنظيم المزيد من هذه الزيارات
روسيا تحترم كافه الاتفاقيات الدوليه
المتعلقه باسرى الحرب اوكرانيا منعت
زيارات اهالي الاسرى ولا يعرف مصيرهم الا
عبر قوائم التبادل
تضاعف عدد الاسرى لدى الجانبين مع احتدام
القتال يستوجب وفق مراقبين تكثيف العمل
بمساعده اطراف خارجيه على هذا الملف كما
على ملفات انسانيه اخرى لا تقل اهميه
كموضوع المفقودين والضحايا من المدنيين
وملف تصدير الحبوب والعوده الى مسار
الحوار امين الجزيره بنيتك